I hello and welcome to this live stream
is anybody around the view account is
still on zero but I don't think this can
be true somebody should be around maybe
we should close the door is anybody
actually around I would the brave the
very in is on high it's not a
single-player live stream I've got a
friend around who wanted to see how
twitch works this is me or Michael hello
hello world in a world yeah and he wants
to he wanted to see how twitch works
it's also a good chess player so maybe
we will cheat a little bit and I let him
play on my account one or two games
don't tell the admins yeah okay so um a
tournament a quick tournament what about
the how are these super blitz we are a
little bit behind here eight points
behind but let's get going yeah we
joined any des mots around I don't think
I get bad yeah Michael is around two
thousand two thousand one hundred so
it's don't I don't think it's cheating
if he plays the only game because I'm
much worse so it's good for the opponent
you might get some cheap rating points
with you hmm I have probably yes sir
2400 yeah so now we got 12 years so here
you see the view account and then it
will go up as William as we continue to
play do they actually play those
tournaments once in my I never know but
maybe I should start them we could do
some head and brain this is actually
true yeah what's that and then brain
yeah you have to tell me what piece I
should move when I should have to figure
out what precise more to play okay this
is actually a good idea but then now we
started the tournament and then we could
do that actually we can do that so this
is I don't think that would be
considered cheating so now I would need
to say Bishop no yeah yeah
I mean this is the Turkish that i have
preserved this game so my time is a
little bit on the lower side I don't
think it makes sense to do a hand and
brain in bullet time so we should
probably start with the next game I
should have grabbed them free in pawn
why didn't I do that was it
isn't it really tough for you if if you
see a nice combination and I say the one
piece let's go
Queen h4 is a bit of a risky pre-move
here but it's kind of kind of funky he
did Bishop earth - okay yeah that's the
fun part of an umbrella exactly my guest
is Misha Ally a friend of mine he wanted
to see how twitch works so be nice to
him I should wonder the Rukia look
before was a great idea that didn't
amount to anything I don't like your
Bishop or the pawn on g7 a bishop looks
bad yeah it looks bad but yeah one of my
favorite things about chess is bad
bishops protect good pawns and this is
one of those cases I didn't I didn't
really see that before but this is a
good rook that I can win the problem at
the end will be that his knight will
come to c5 and my position is probably
crap yeah this is not good him but this
guy doesn't play 1700 anyplace well I
mean well as is a bit much but better
than 1700 no swearing of course no
swearing yeah I mean he's got a he's got
a draw in hand now and I have this
feeling that he will probably take it
yeah and what should maybe play for we
played for him and he can play for when
ip7 does actually win that's made up
windy I'd made
so I feel good at items again now that
wasn't good that was not good
NEC is also it's here in the tundra now
you see that I'm streaming and what was
this berserk berserk Inge you can get an
extra point in the tournament but you
get your thymus is reduced to 50% so so
the coolest thing you can do on this
side is to play a 30 second bullet
tournament at berserk - 15 seconds so
you have to say my moves now I mean
that's all I say
okay tonight we ship Bishop no okay okay
that's good
pawn again but it's three minutes it's
very tough Bishop it is really but you
can like cheat you always you can you
know put your okay King yeah I could
take yeah I should probably put the
mouse belong with the board
Bishop Knight and at the end dr. drunken
only will win yeah probably right but
Meghan around it's tough in three
minutes yeah it really is tough night
rook yeah you get dang over yeah you
have to be quick okay
well that's pretty tough isn't it like
the last minute you yeah the last twenty
seconds or so I have to I have to rock
again
yeah brave the rain is right yeah it's
it's a bit tough in three minutes but
we're doing okay Brooke we do okay yeah
at the end yet dr. drunken sue banana
sister this is a cardinal yeah and that
is like what Gary Lineker said about
Fiona Germany football is 11 people
chasing after born in the end Germany
wins and if you if you do a bullet
tournament only chess it's 200 title
players competing at the end card
night I know Tony tax that sounds German
so what are you doing there don't you
have to work okay phone porn yeah no I
want to change it now now you can make a
bomb of itself terrible
maybe 9 f7 was was on the air 897 King
takes a check through sugar 500 thanks
for the cheer break the very end now you
can do it even better
yeah nice yeah this sounds pretty it
looks pretty good so Bishop I can say
pre-pre can I was freed and pre brain or
something pretty brain sounds sounds
wrong somehow so and now you're even up
on time that's good yeah being up on
time is always helpful
Oh easy simply didn't take it ok so
they should Bishop okay
must be Bishop d6 then yeah everything
else would be too fancy Bishop g6 quits
a good one hmm
Queen no I make make the night make
tonight
Queen is okay actually I couldn't go
Queenie - that's nothing bad about it
what is it visit bad I don't see it
and hello to dust whistling yeah good
and talk what are all those Germans
doing it don't you have to work Germans
are at work look I should put the name
of my guest in the title of the stream
and that's probably true I have no clue
how I modified the stream child and once
I'm streaming probably I can't
it was a pretty spontaneous decision to
do that so I your student uh-huh
okay so pawn pawn and it's up to you
which one these were the pot I have some
choice em that's good I can modify right
in the dashboard okay sorry hey but it's
kind of clear that I have to take oh
sorry
no so yeah but this I mean we can still
do it
yeah the point we bought you you needed
to take okay
no I didn't need to take rookie five
here was better you know yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're right that was just
but to love those end games where you
can make your opponent suffer they're
just like automatic I don't like a
knight on e4
yeah now that was good day I should get
some material back end that's well it
makes sense but I think I'm going to win
some something back one thing is clear
we're not queen queen we have to do it
we're not going to win this event yeah
we're the first
I bungled up the first game there was
zero points and somebody has 20 points
which is crazy high between pre queen
pre Queen Queen and it's it's too heavy
can you can easily pre move that oops
sorry
and no it's make a mixture of porn and
King yeah good firm permanent porn booze
but we win on time yeah it was good that
was very very very very clean win um
well just one for just one thing um how
do I modify the free end stream name
like here in the dashboard you say on
the dashboard where is that in the
dashboard like here or something I hear
the routine like you okay said did I
save that yes and please night okay porn
if 96 you can make it prom move please
okay
and later on night
yeah and night again I would like to see
no no not here I can make it at me yeah
and I know you like to play this
variation more than the Bishop III let's
also make the night move thing okay so
let's do this Knight Bishop Bishop okay
mm yeah this is a kind of position where
you would want to play a certain line
anyway let's do it
I mean this is still okay of course it
can never be terrible make Bishop again
Bishop again you have to watch out
normally you play this line with an
early Queen e2 and Bishop e3 oh sorry
III and Castle long yeah I wanted yet no
that no the Queen also and our time is
kind of a crappy no Queen okay the time
the time bug Castle castle you're
cheating two options you know I could
play kinky to em Queen rook
centralized when in doubt centralized
night position is okay
our time is not so right yeah 95 you
would probably go on he after yes to do
it
mmm-hmm let's stop Queen it's a tough
tough me I think this is best
Queen Queen move pawn pawn okay I'm
going to try this I'm not sure therefore
there were many many good options not
sure that was good yeah but you only
please I told you I this is your night
Jen I don't be 3s it's not good angry
King move please you studied lots of
prophylactics no Knight III check and I
don't know
night no night make the cream please
let's let's go out of this potential
trouble now the night the the square on
f5 looks so juicy yeah you will take it
him I will do this primo in case oh he's
not taking it
I like night again that was debatable
you an idea 5 also was good so you have
a very long time apparently is point
please please okay I don't know when
we're down when I'm on 20 seconds I have
to do it on my own yeah I think that's a
fair agreement pawn do we have increment
by the way no no oh no this is this is
real deal I'm Tom and night take it
greed is good
and you should know that right the greed
is good with your Mott Street stuff
noise yeah yeah no I would say it
doesn't matter what you move from
probably probably probably 20 seconds
it's the first Wall Street huh
let's it's the first one yeah the Gordon
Gordon Gekko by Michael Douglas
I like the big short I think about the
housing bubble yeah you know I watched
that I watched that coming back from the
tournament opponent oh really yeah they
had it on the bus yeah yeah pong they
had it on the bus night they had a
night they had they had local bishop
they had some local disk on the bus and
then they had it on the they had
Wireless and you could watch movies that
was cool and it was one of them yeah how
many I was porn we had seven hours sauce
right it was a lot of movies you can
watch yeah I was cool on this should i
when you watch sorry yeah okay I can't
do the night now
I say yeah you don't have to I would
like to see me waiting move make thanks
for the donation Sookie
and a lot of folks yeah yeah you're the
first motor round yes so make sure
everybody wishes be bishop okay yeah
this movie the big short I heard it was
fairly accurate right I liked it very
much and not so much choice he plays
really first and you we play low slow um
King pawn pawn this is so much choice
pointed pawn is good point it's good but
I don't know where there are many pawns
I just see one there are many of them
many of them come on let's do something
that's the one I wanted to see
se6 was also a decent choice I think
simply get rid of the limiting pawns
strategically sound like your bishop on
97 is this like this guy will do
something in the end I I feel that's a
black shock it's our bolo gun like and I
remember the game was Kasparov when he
had the Kings Indian and he moved like
the queen bee eight and I'm certain
against I don't know
look please look please use every single
piece improve our recipes yes yes come
on we are all over him here right Oh
make a poem please porn please okay did
you calculate that up to the end you
know I've called upon h3 you can also oh
this is funky what is he doing porn
again porn again now you can do what do
you want to do therefore or something
huh I'm always I'm always I would have
gone 95 I always like to jump into f3
but okay let's go ahead for that's the
one I wanted to do I thought everything
now is it's it's good it's a good move
it's not a bad move at least Anna tell
you the bishop on a sudden mmm I smell
blood a new queen no you know they
always they always forget about this
piece yeah I have taken on g3 so often
that rook rook the rook is easy
Queen Queen again this looks pretty good
what is she what is she a new ello by
the way after the tournament about 2000
of him but I had a score of 2250 yeah it
was there was a really good tournament
you have to give me the game sponsor why
did you it gave you did she give me the
games yeah I wanted to do some
commentaries or at least that you can
see what's my queen looks pretty good
Queen Queen Queen queen you want to take
there right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
threatened yeah yeah yeah I know we are
first we are first Queen
no night I would like to do a night fire
yeah it's the only night move that
doesn't blunder made mm-hmm good pawn
queen I can also do this chick you know
now you can think about it again make
the bishop bishop you know you can get
to some sort of ending a piece down I
thought anyway pawn thought some group
f/64 cetera you can do it now with 18
seconds you can do it on your own I
probably have to 16 seconds still it's
still not so easy with the time I mean
yeah I feel like we probably had some
some quicker kill available but I'm
fairly comfortable with the three
protected connected passes here this
King looks a little bit lonely on the
King side yeah I need I need more I need
the King looking all the way up to age
three or something the bullet tournament
yesterday does help you know everything
went three minutes eyelids feels like a
correspondence game you know it really
does yeah
so six seconds mmm I would probably a
long time
I have a long time hmm okay now we have
no chance and then how can you see how
many people are know on this and we have
got 61 so of your 61 it's not bad you
know it's I mean it's not the best time
ever here because who will America is
sound asleep almost or they am kind of
at home or in church praying or
something they cannot time to do it in
Germany they cannot take care about what
shares and German say they they're
always they're always working you know
so Phillip Phillip of pawn Tommy
borealis running pawn okay the time
Memorial is running really since when
actually I saw tall when he played in
pots hmm yeah you you were luckier to
participate yeah and sorry it's now I
was making say resumes
sorry hey you have night night yeah you
were luckier you I also participated in
the in the in the ports open a couple of
times but I played in 1993 and 1994 and
that was an it stopped almost for the
day they stopped at some point and that
was after Todd item pong okay I think
there's a book out with the Brier
variation on menu but a relatively new
repertoire did you say something or you
I like I know that you play 95 so make
the night move you can do the good thing
is the flexibility here do they play
pong here I don't know
you should go see five that dead fish I
don't know
Bishop Bishop Bishop okay mmm
Queen let's go here what do you do with
a knight on a five in this position so
in some sometimes no I don't know Knight
yeah I'm sorry I didn't didn't quite
hear it yeah I never play position like
this with leg saw yeah maybe yeah
reminds me a little bit of the Kings
Indian structure where you play on the
Kings side but right there yeah I made a
mistake I should have gone c-51 probably
it's more your area or areas pretty bad
English a field of expertise what about
pawn with your visit is it yeah it is
or did you want to make another point
this but it was not sure and I think
about another pawn of year again yeah
yeah you have to do this it's that's
fairly ok for black pawn again born
again ok
isn't it good to have this pawn on c4
now yeah
probably yes Knight I like to see night
I don't like to see that no I would have
absolutely I thought about the yeah I'm
thinking about it I'm thinking about it
don't think about hey I rewrite your
accurate puh pawn yeah porn ok I wanted
to go Bishop see it so that whenever he
goes here we are ready to I want to have
my Kings Indian structure here you know
so I don't know
make a move yeah when he taxes right I
think with the knight on c3 white would
be fine
it's problem to ignite yeah that's
probably true but he does not have the
knight on c3 Knight mate I wanted to
stop him to play a four but now he can
always play it huh
oh no no Knight h5 is coming mmm it's
it's on the agenda yeah our time the
time the duration time time is not on
our side or something like that they've
really ever what is the town memoria the
city in Moscow or something probably yes
okay no you can move on your own 36
seconds okay thirty Seconds to Mars or
something well this looks pretty good
your Center this is the kind of thing
even if it works it works really well
but you need to explain me why you
didn't like 94 I thought you might enjoy
a four before yeah because then you have
the pressure on the L file he can never
play a four I thought and this kind of
structure he could always play a form
that would be look at this trick yeah I
could have done that I think I could
have done that it wouldn't it wouldn't
have been bad
I said good actually that I'm I could do
it I can take one either wait isn't he
takes himself that's kind of funny
that's going to be a time winner but
this bizarre thing stuff has nothing to
do like like like you can double up the
score but you need to win you know I
know just the time it's just a time when
you you yeah like you get four points
for wind if you own a streak yeah and if
you berserk you get five or if you yeah
the single witness three points and yeah
just a little bit of an extra night
night oh we're not we're not even in the
Indus in this leaderboard yeah what are
we doing here we keep waiting why do you
want everything right not the first 1.8
mm okay the term the more is actually
rapid rapid 25 plus 10 okay you ever
wondered on mid-river sir go before he
takes with my night let's see if we can
shock the white player a little bit
black player a little bit I have no clue
if that's good but it looks really cool
huh is it working
let's see if not it would be at or crap
you know I think we change him so nice
do I want this or this and Queen I think
I what about what about porn and that
can only mean you want to go see five
yes I thought maybe yeah I'm not sure
yeah what's I'm not sure but it's
possible hmm Bishop yeah you can try
that but I have no clue if it's any good
but that's your your your thing then
shout out some I have no clue if it is
any good yeah mm maybe not maybe it is I
don't know let's take it very unclear to
me if that is a good good idea or not I
wanted to make the other I thought okay
you some genius stuff no I just blended
the other I just completely forgot that
the route can take I completely forget
that you can take I thought about you
know Bishop b2 and releasing one before
Bishop aids-free world also okay I think
okay but now you have to fight c5 c5 was
okay you know but I have to fight yeah
you make it alone and try to rescue
those yeah I mean I killed it yeah I
think I can always say I thought
something different if you make a
mistake
you know yeah it makes it's really
really good
I have the feeling you've been on time
he he becomes nervous that he might win
he told me yeah it looks like it well
one thing that is really in our not in
our favor is that opponent has a light
squared bishop and that that really is a
this can be a real powerhouse I know he
will probably take it look it's a really
bad game I mean barely played by me most
of mostly what it's just black quicker I
think he will win if you play quicker
yeah probably he's very nervous because
he he wants to be known I mean he he can
take on b3 but he doesn't do it for some
reason yeah he dreams of a checkmate
only two so I maybe have some there are
some yeah I mean that's understandable
yeah it's an understandable idea I would
better rank me the back rank stuff yeah
there is there is back rank stuff yeah I
mean not not really but you know I know
constantly and now you regret that he
plays so slow and that's oh that looks
wrong that is definitely wrong I mean at
least we get some material back
okay yeah well what now act 25 or
something okay that that ending is
completely okay for us unless I'm
blundering stuff again
yeah but your time is so good now yeah
yeah and he's not getting any quicker
yeah absolutely not we can trade the
rope here I'm starting to be better even
for real not just on the clock now it
gets a lot better yeah yeah you right
yeah it was just simply simply too slow
it reminded me of the game Carlton
against Wayne Jones when he was like it
was like I work on some blunder and then
he became and it was really tough to
play what I would have to play I think
it was really tough to play but I think
he became also notice I mean you have to
chance
swish against the world champion fortune
and what is it like Paul yes I like to
see the phone again please pawn Knight
no no not phone you can play the night
also goes well it's actually pretty easy
you have you have a knight Knight
yeah yeah you have to like it's like the
elephant variation just reversed a
little bit yeah but okay
d5 is just a pawn up for the floor for
nothing this is just the transposition
no Knight Bishop c4 yeah Knight pawn
pawn next move is lucky okay
if you want to take I want to Bishop
yeah they give me a bishop this one
sorry for free I will take it oh it's
the weather indeed slacking cold yes
it's friggin cold okay but you don't
pawn again you didn't want to play we
should be four before no okay
inside it's a week also I want to
torture myself with the bed bishop no
you put your mouse on the on the night
already so I think we you know just to
Oh make that you need to make something
different just I'm not doing it on
purpose I can farm move please
and that's all of us minnows F glad that
there were new tax okay Bishop Bishop
okay maybe you're right yeah it was some
poaching megaweapon yeah sending us if I
say rook you can also decide if you
Castle her actually I saw a bits game of
cap off where you wanted to Castle and
he touched the rock first mm-hmm but I
mean okay Paul Gray I like I like the
King side attack
did you take their actually this is a I
don't know I would play rook or Bishop
move or what I'm not sure if I really
want to take on g5 you hate me I take
taking yeah the problem is simply the
time yeah King King
what deck king
yeah Edward King Wow there are no tricks
okay okay rook Oh No yeah I takes Knight
takes rook takes I can't take no more of
40 seconds again so you cannot just yeah
I'm going to go into full scale hustle
mode here it's okay you know the
position is I mean it's probably you
don't do it but it's reasonably close
you know
this is not so easy to win that's kind
of a kind of bad we can take one h5 Lala
that'sthat's the moment where it really
gets bad but he wanted to open the h5
for you yeah yeah yeah we would play for
me to him I went blunder London blue wow
that's a really really bad position
really bad yeah I know
what was that focus on I'm will below 20
seconds or something okay Knight h5
everything wins is the problem not
everything wins prolly
beginning ending I'm actually reasonably
happy that I'm not mated but it's
completely lost of course not bad not
that wasn't that wasn't barely played by
white at all you know I think white
played that quite well I mean you can
also argue that I played crap but he
played well I also wonder I mean they
all have like 1700 but I have a feeling
they play yeah yeah they played better
but that wasn't really that was a really
bad so long seven seconds you can you
can do it yeah some three moves yeah you
can I'm hoping for a stalemate you know
can always do that I have to get rid of
my pawns it's just you never resigned
never resign normal surrender I should
probably resign he's getting he's
getting somewhat that was bad
you know I think that was um that was
really shaky maybe you should just play
some very quick games on your own
without hunting style we only have five
this is one game okay so let's make pawn
and then the king move order then the
King me yes that's a bong cloud right
yes I saw it when a camera played it so
come on just try it okay I really don't
like this I like to see you suffer oh my
god and you continue to say so you can
you can know in one sense you need to
play alone never wanders alone okay I'm
playing it so badly
animating immediately no you can run on
h2 it's a very safe place hey it's me no
no it's it's it's already checkmate
Bishop f2 King edge to Queen f4 is made
I know it's not made as I'm here okay
okay
it looks very safe it's very safe
you were illness if I get the Queen's
off yeah I can probably probably claim
compensation hmm maybe this is just a
phone I should maybe I can do stuff here
on the dark squeeze a little bit I have
five the way it's the thing and five is
a real issue here the ruble h1 is not
there's a good piece you know
the rook is not at all I wonder if he
goes this year if he goes F for if my
bishop is completely trapped but don't
you like your [ __ ] there a little bit
yeah I always like the bishop parent
this is not this is not really really
nice
let's not play the bong cloud this is
really not a good idea you will win this
game I mean and then yeah I mean then
you have a hundred percent score with
yes and everybody will be afraid when
you play Keeney - next time no I don't
think so
it's taking far too long yeah for for
such a position because it didn't know
the opening it's pretty no no sorry only
text I haven't haven't her to write
anything about the commentary schedule I
have no clue is right Erik's you must be
a good friend since you allow him to
renew a thing yeah that we go to the
vision homepage says cannot read
property posts of undefined you know
this is a professional website or fede
you know you know that feed is also
professional so you know you know what
black is doing is playing for drawing he
wants to completely close down
everything and hope to make a draw
and you will do the neck Amuro style and
just play on time later on I don't know
I don't know if you can do something
here can that somehow win de-spawn
probably not know yeah if you notice you
know I go with the king to d3 first and
I can try the thing is if I win this
what what kind of ending is that it's
not the best ending ever you know the
good thing is that black will almost
assured what about going to d7 and D 550
lows that's a good idea
okay I should have gone there anyway now
he's afraid this okay really that's
energy form and the way he plays that he
cannot win but he can probably not lose
either at least not on pollution I just
say the thing is just seven seconds huh
yeah I would say it's a draw and then is
a reputation action well that's fair I
mean I don't like I don't like all these
just playing for time so what's that
yeah so the tournament is over we did a
late join and didn't didn't do all that
well but it really I mean this is this
is this is 44 is crazy high that's a lot
just lonely just lost one game they lost
one game and when he got in many games
this is actually not that easy if you
look at this year
look at us yeah we we had four games we
had eight games and yeah eight and he
had like six eight eleven thirteen years
so he wanted even one many minutes very
late like I thought yeah five minutes
eight minutes or something and there was
really really really really so good good
thing to know would be how many points
did you lose I mean raining points yes
like my head 32,400 at the beginning and
lost like 16 so that's quite a lot
Oh Nico it's fierce you're the really
could see as a blazing mullah right and
then you're strong and you shouldn't
join and killer it's not a good idea
okay we mostly started this dream to to
figure out how twitch works and my
friend wanted to check how this works so
um so what should we do
actually what should we do play some
play some viewer challenges anybody
around to challenge us
so Neko if you are round and give us a
challenge she'll give me a challenge
it's my account now a lot of Simula no
not that not that long event event
that's possible it's possible that Misha
will do a Twitter stream as well
do you don't have an account yet or
twitch right or do you have one
mmm I have one but it's not on stream
yeah it's it's drawing I have this
channel on YouTube start a long time ago
which I don't use at the moment maybe
let's start again okay we've got some
challenges and it's an equal challenging
maybe later but Baxter says is in the
channel so where are you Baxter I don't
see you do you see Baxter you can you
can do 3 minutes if you like uncle
where's Baxter I saw him at the very top
so just a normal game well just a just a
normal gamer get some rating points back
9 is ready
it's really not so important i nico your
first night okay so play the Bishop b5
yeah my line I want to see Bishop d7 and
c4 that stuff
let's see just in case you're guessing
no I'm not
just pouring tea that's what is Baxter
doing I mean he says he hates this check
yeah it what happened it will happen and
more often than not people have
recognized that the night ov is a pretty
good opening so we will turn we will
build what do you think about ninety
seven isn't like ninety seven more like
a like a fight suggestion or Bishop d7
more like four draw yeah yeah
ninety-seven I think that's probably
what I would play myself and go into
some sort of Spanish structure with b5
and d5 and it's a very decent very
decent type of setup that you can play
also to win no with black it's more
because column like that I think King
also recommended this is an old book
it's it's really ok I'm not entirely
certain about this set up I think it
might be possible something like B 5 B 5
Bishop C 2 B should be seven this is
probably probably a possible idea but
it's [ __ ] something in this game can
he play and listen at the same time now
that's possible yeah that's possible of
course and I think sometimes I mean not
not like in this kind of scenario like
here with with the twitch chat but I
don't sometimes think I'm doing
simultaneous display sometimes so for
the ICC or I do a bento blitzes for four
chests when you form and sometimes
especially in the context of the ICC
simians I sometimes feel they listen in
and they benefit from from like I'm
suggesting moves like I'm expecting
black to move this and that and then
they just play it you know this is
possible but I think it's it's part of
the deal but something you do like like
five seconds delay for stream or
something yeah yeah yeah I don't I'm not
sure if you can set this up maybe you
can but
[Music]
but well I mean it's not it's not like
we're fighting for Olympic medals yeah
so and here you can see at the top that
like seven challenges or yeah yeah
there's seven challenges out and this is
the notification bell which I don't know
what it is okay so I'm just going to
going to centralize everything
when in doubt centralized he's got night
aged 5 now which is a good movie good
movie about Baxter is going against
Knight f4 and general speaking yeah they
said today you know you're right yeah
this is a good argument tends to boy
says there are poker streams and they
should have delay mm yeah that that
makes a lot of sense
okay so Knight age 5 I don't like this
too much like my position all that much
and I don't have a clear idea what to do
okay this is kind of a gamble if he
doesn't take up play - mhm - and if he
does I hope I get something what the
heck that cannot be a good move I don't
believe that yes but I cannot so I can
take g6 and even if I take that's hard
to believe
he's got Bishop g5 but is that really
all that bad I don't see it
Bishop g5 maybe he can go Bishop g5
Queen was Knight f4 it looks that looks
weird but
the only tax Fe now we worked out if you
can visit the burning candidates or not
I know you said you were thinking about
it and he will likely meet you yeah it's
possible we've met before though is one
of them he's involved in junior coaching
for for what is that like Sonya Saxon
and so we met in willing in more than
once
yeah I don't know yeah I think somehow I
feel black is doing a good job and I do
I like all those pieces around your king
yeah I know that you don't feel
comfortable when you are so many yeah it
looks it looks good it looks weird yeah
it really looks weird to me 20 NDA
somehow continuously refuses to check
you know it's five plus three okay I
only I only saw that now it's good that
you say it because it's um it's really a
little bit out of the ordinary so came
cymatic here Queen cakes I cannot really
I cannot allow that yeah my dad check
check check check check check
could be drawn 19th of March Issus I
think you were there yeah if I take
these three and twin shakes
I mean black is not threatening a maid
here I think with the night only four
I'm not getting chicken rated but it
doesn't feel very nice you know he has a
draw in hand shouldn't play queen f1 him
that's not a good one yeah Baxter what
are you doing there him completely
completely out playing me only tax
you're thinking about buying a gold
ticket it's for the backstage the goat
yeah the gold ticket for the candidate
involves yeah yeah some of those some of
those things yeah I feel it makes it
impossible to get information about the
event that's somewhat true okay so I
have to cover this and shouldn't blunder
the house so that that's what I have to
do here couldn't be three maybe okay I'm
kind of I'm kind of sick of this stuff
I don't want to ignore I might want to
bend the idiot
okay so Bishop e5 I can't go Queen jf7
probably probably I should do that
always stay on the light square it yeah
I think black is not making progress
that's what I was wondering now if you
would if you wear black if you would try
to win this I have no idea how it
stopped
I have no obvious idea who's Jim penguin
penguin Jam who that is yeah that's
anything that's one is a super-fast
player most of my own I'm frigging
seminar my students yeah black and
always draw
and probably I mean I don't really see
anything better you probably have to do
it yeah it looked like a very good game
a black him what do you think yeah India
ffs I've looked insane to be honest but
maybe this was like I thought it was a
Muslim or something but yeah yeah but it
was it was strong yeah it was strong I
was just wondering if also the stream I
mean you can play and also watch the
stream if there are some guys like
giving hints you can also see it right
yeah this is actually true in some cases
in some cases I feel yeah good luck you
come in some in some cases I feel this
is also helping me I had this once in a
while yeah because it's some some people
here are really strong players in the
chat you know and in some cases some
hints are really helpful I mean like
ticktick honey taxis a 2100 something
and he sometimes says couldn't you do
that and like it was still relevant
information yeah and and I thought I
didn't I don't remember exactly what
kind of stream it was maybe put
something from chest I'll come over
wherever or just 24 well where you have
this valuation bar on the left side yeah
and there was a stream going on and you
could see it I mean and then I also
thought okay I mean even the strong
players it's valuable to see the
machines go right yeah it is it was a
good game by Baxter really are you
familiar with this rule applies
repertoire I think I had this kind of
position on the board like a million
times I mean literally a million times
actually very good player Nico is I
think a good F M Nico from from the
Netherlands you plays formula
yeah this is I always compare this the
habit of playing the slyness like like
smoking yeah you know you shouldn't do
it it's unhealthy and still you can stop
my score is still good yeah with this
weird line
it's Michael a title player no not yet
he's working on it but yeah so what is
this position he said equal its that
better for black it said better for
white what do you think I want to win
this okay Queenie r3 is not the most
difficult move ever then I have Queenie
Wonder and I've got Bishop g5 the good
thing is if you've played this a lot
you're going to make a million moves
quickly I once had this opening this
closed ruined in a blitz game in the
German team blitz against Grandmaster
blastema yawns ah he's a veteran GMS in
the 60's and yonder is still a really
good player but in this blitz tournament
I mean we played and I played the moves
like instantly and it was crazy I had
like a minute spent that he was close to
losing on time yeah this is really funny
and do you often in this kind of
structures problems with your bishop
like yeah I mean the blacks weren't
Bishop and you have all the pawns on the
black squares that you have problems and
endings or no no you can often exchange
the bishop and everything so and you can
you can exchange stuff here this is
unfortunately just to draw of it it's
what it is
you should probably let's fight
okay it was not it was not the most most
exciting game ever I want to give other
guys a chance to play so I'm not doing
rematches Thank You Nico who else is on
there
hey MJ m zg j is was in the chat i think
just a moment ago yeah good luck so I
should have done something different
maybe just for variation
did you see the bishop before line of
Magnus he recently played against what
against any contribution p5 yeah in
played this against in the Roy against
your Maya
yes exactly yes skill and he started to
fit have a long thing in the opening and
yeah okay that we should be for line
it's not great but when he said it it's
not to sell it in the in during the game
it's not a good line if you know it was
right but yeah most people don't know I
mean yeah you never look at the stuff
him why didn't you want to put the
bishop on d6 because I felt the ephah
could open it so because I was just
eyeing on h2 and like an instant 56 ago
that I think yeah maybe
no Mike let's not my student but we've
been friends for a while it was a form
of work made of mind that was a quick
move and maybe not that great on the
resting of it every year 96 yeah luckily
I want to trade this one off and we've
broken the 100 viewer barrier yeah but
it's um I think it gets higher the later
it gets time was because you
people in Germany coming back from work
or from school and the same as the u.s.
guys they're close to their to their
lunch breaks and so on him yeah I mean
all the people who fell asleep they're
still counting you yeah yeah hello to
Texas on 59 we all ready yes exactly yes
tens of while you're right Michael was
the one who told me to do a chest video
on YouTube exactly the one how long is
it ago no it's like it was July 2011
July 2011 and yeah you know I mentioned
you when I was having the interview I
really yeah I was having this interview
on the perpetual chest podcast that I
mentioned earlier and then asked me okay
how did that YouTube channel started and
I told it as it as it was that you asked
me to do to do a video and explain what
I was thinking during the Blitz game
yeah this this game is getting downhill
for white
I'll take everything yeah thanks for the
game okay so who else is on the
winter-like stiii got a couple of
regulars I think Tushar comme des
mentioned that he's in the Chet and
Jesse just isn't just for newbies okay
so to Sean today we played much of E for
what do you do usually do you go D for
most of the time but why don't you play
b3 make the Java style b3 and I know
it's lame I can do it b3 later I like
what I think about b3 sometimes is you
have like and sometimes like a night of
structure a Sicilian if you follow the
c4 III here and sometimes you have like
a names or Queen's Indian with the
Templar hmm very often and if you know
those openings with black
very good I don't know most people don't
face b3 that much yeah if you know that
is true well but the funny thing is that
even nowadays yeah you get many books
many a strong one some books really
covering black repertoire yeah again
stuff like that hey there so really
there's this book by um
McAuliffe ski yeah that covers all the
minor openings here and he's got
everything here from g4 to before why
and what not yet okay and I mean even
yet even covers c4 and I have three
basically everything besides d4 and e4
and it's it's funny to see that even
stuff like that gets coverage now at ASM
which might also be one reason might be
that they simply feel a man when he can
generate some sort of interest they make
a book of it okay I was also thinking to
take on aged seven when I wasn't sure if
that would work maybe it worked actually
oh it worked you know I could have taken
check root page 896 check with the Queen
but maybe I take rook check Luke H a
takes nine to six changes in a queen
life that was too much material I guess
anyway this is not bad but he's got f5
which is kind of a but in the end you
also I mean this Bishop on p7 it doesn't
look good him know that doesn't work
that does not work it's a pre move for
made and sometimes say if you play in
corn plates you can earn two points you
can win one point on the board in the
second point you can earn if you get
more time at the end and you started
with which was close five minutes you
can increment lets you get three seconds
to move if you yeah if you end up with
four points if you know of course not
greater this might be I mean
you have like two different ratings for
white and black would be fair
also if you play much quicker than
someone I don't know yeah I forgot it
again I wanted to play me three do it in
the second move if he plays c6 you can
ad I can play me three yeah now probably
not there what is it if you play by the
way c4 in second rule fear it's not so
great those kind of structures like the
pot Phoenix system and you know I I hate
this on the board once in the Dutch
league and I played 96 and then f5 ah it
means I just played a faster mmm yeah no
Mike that's not my student when we talk
about chess but when we don't have
lessons different ratings for white and
black an interesting idea yeah I think
it makes sense I mean I'm not so much in
favor of separate ratings but I think
you should have the expected value of
points should be different I said I
think because if you are in a final
round game let's say and you need a
certain score for scoring a norm for
example white it's just so much easier I
mean you can also check out the
databases if you screen a player for
white and black the average rating he
cheats with white is often like 50 100
one side of them like yeah it's a it's a
big difference
I mean it's specially I feel sorry to
interrupt you but this is your scotch
that's a squadron but how on earth have
I spent so much time and didn't really
didn't really I wonder what I spent the
time one was probably I would we
discussed the b3 stuff at the beginning
because I scurried obvious nobody that
this thing if you need a certain result
in the final round of open tournaments
for example for norm why it is so much
easy you cannot believe it it's such
though it's just so much easier do you
remember what I sometimes wonder
with black of course if you need to win
it for a supergreat GM against another
very hard but there was one feeder I
don't know stuff going on where where
kramnik plates played against Greece
shook and Greece shook you know he
started to draw made other yeah yeah we
okay but Greece jokes idea was that he's
really great in Blitzen rabbit and he
wanted to blitz games to happen okay
well I think it was even at the end he
didn't want to he needed to win like two
two games were left and he needs to win
one and he made a draw I mean he needed
to win so um
okay well there was a bit strange I know
I remember that was the the Kazan
matches and in 2011 that was a bit
strange but I had the feeling like like
he knows how kramnik trains you know and
that he has a lot of huge repertoire and
that he maybe thought okay I don't have
anything against his repertoire that he
just gave up before the game started
already I don't know I think I think the
the situation that I mostly had in mind
was when I was playing for international
master norms and you need a draws in a
certain situation it's just so much
easier with wide yeah there are some
situations where let's say the opponent
every game plays a Slav defense and you
have the white pieces you can basically
you have Nayla you just trade on d5 and
you're not losing against I don't know
if you have a reasonable chance to
become an IM you shouldn't do this
against and I am when there's the Slav
exchange or let's say they play the
French a you play the French exchange
and then and you just go home and and
then you've done it yeah Bishop f5 is an
interesting move here I was I'm
basically blitzing with King f2 and so
on but I should have thought about that
maybe he can do that and trade a bit
gain the e4 square for the knight that
could be interesting him I have a very
comfortable ending him but I did not
think about that what I liked when you
talk about the norms is what yes sir on
once said in a stream and
I mean of course if you play for the
norm you want to achieve the norm but
you said something similar in the lines
that you already have the master
strength the international masses means
if you if you if you try to get the norm
so it doesn't really matter if you get
to normal like a little bit earlier or
later you just play the games and if you
have the strengths to get it it was a
it's definitely true yeah it's
definitely true it just I've always felt
like like mathematically speaking in
such a situation it's just so much more
difficult if you have like yes it really
is more difficult
I mean it's achieving it if you if you
have the strength and so on that that's
all true but it is just like it's a
difficult it's a different situation in
some way okay what do i do I should I
should get out of this friggin third
ring and I do I will throw things so
it's it's it's reap last one yeah that's
it for me I'm not just good question
will we go out for beer afterwards
probably not I have to go to my chess
club and we have our monthly training
session there so I have to talk for
three hours about Brooke endings which
sounds like not much fun even better if
you're drunk
it's been a better one admit about doing
that doing the word wrong is you're
certainly true you're right
we actually have be at the Chess Club
iam vision I should I should try that
okay thanks for the game chest for
newbies who else ah that's cool let's do
that let's do this one
chess960 oh yes I love that yeah I hope
that will be more and more let's do that
hoping for b6 and I but I'm not familiar
with those castling rules there I
like how do you move if you Castle like
technically or how technically yeah
would you even always the King and then
play also like in the know what you do
you just I would I can cancel short and
I would move the King onto onto the rook
and then I got King to g11 and do all
the pieces need to be away yeah yeah
yeah in order to cancel short I have to
get rid of everything here
everything okay the bishop can stay I
really yeah and we should pinch okay
okay yeah that's a really long short
castle and if I can so long the rook
jumps to d1 and the King to c1 so it's
it's really funky so I'll take that
what is this this is chess960 or fish a
random I was surprised that they had it
called fish a random again when they did
this tournament with Carlton and in turn
a camera because I thought they would
have gotten rid of the Fisher end of a
thing because it sounds kind of negative
and this is why they did when they
called it chess960 Hewitt and wasn't it
Bronstein even that invented it before
now once a grant Steen had had this
other time control invented that
somewhat similar to the Fisher turn
control I think Bronstein invented if
I'm not wrong I could be wrong with the
delay time control I could be wrong
though what I'm doing here is I just
just for the fun of it want to castle
let's see if I can't kill the castle a
short will be cool thing here Bishop F
to Queen out and then castle short
it's right and when he takes a
Braunstein is it's the it's the delay
time control I'm very certain that this
is the case it was always like on the
back of the GGG clocks and when I heard
about the delay time control used in the
use in the u.s. I felt this is what is
on the clocks as Braunstein so we've got
a 111 viewers that's cool another reason
to drink some stuff you know yeah yeah
the schnapps I yes okay so do we take I
don't know if we do what I would go for
it I think I can gain all the space here
right oh that's this moment where you
really feel that was a bad idea and you
know what the worst thing is you can't
castle anymore huh
I cannot a castle yeah yeah yeah and and
a Scott night before this is the worst
part of it it's not like he takes I mean
he catered to that in 90 you yeah I can
cast along now which is extremely
quickly one foot yeah I'm just saying I
can carry along but like Kings who see
one Luke to d1 but and this is totally
hanging I mean this is ah but you're up
in time it's very rare that you at one
time I thought you are the slowest
player on earth but three three plus two
we am this is this is actually bad here
because I cannot try to win on time
actually I had one game in the last
tournament where my opponent after 25
moves was down to one minute and then
the rest of the game like the next 40
minutes you were always played in 30
seconds Oh some people can be really as
strong in this kind of extreme
situations
so this one maybe I can establish the
spawn down yeah I wish I wish I did okay
now you didn't play against crucial yeah
actually I once played against Islands I
told the story and just before the
stream on a on a server I played against
a guy who wanted to play like five
minutes plus two seconds and we played
the game and he busted me but then he
wanted to play against fight again and I
thought I don't like the time control
and then later on I saw it was Anna and
he was just starting to play on this
gentleman had a very low light writing
so actually yeah I just cancelled long I
couldn't they couldn't preserve that
poem no I can say I even didn't want to
play second game yeah you never you
never know where so this is so nice and
the internet that you can play against
anyway yeah yeah I think I think you're
not that many that was back in the day
as you said on the chess base server
yeah and this is like I don't know 10
years ago so on I think it's weird that
were just getting totally killed here
but I think the problem was that you
cannot recover here from this Bishop
before yeah I was a a quick move that
wasn't really thought out at all but not
sacrificing on c6 and night maybe you
have something like 94 96 yeah I played
a regular chess quite a bit it's just
that I had a challenge for chess960 so I
wanted to want to accept it look it's
down to 7 seconds now isn't it really
hard to
I was something now maybe it's possible
right getting any quicker
Oh t-bone what are you doing you need to
need some caffeine boost or something
airplay quicker I was too slow
I was really too slow okay thanks of the
game t-bone
who else is on yet anybody around the
house has subscribed earlier winter is
coming
the Avant on the way to her bowl of the
five plus three is pretty long it's a
bit it's a bit long yeah but isn't that
shed I think somebody mentioned that
he's Jay he did fire Christine so let's
do it yeah winter is coming and that's a
double tight right there is a Kasparov
and Game of Thrones and it's both I
guess he never saw that one
hi I got jeans go ahead you're like star
it's Rita Julia sorry yeah the games in
Berlin started 3 p.m. that's true
no I didn't I didn't read anything as
far off road that was not about yes I am
yeah I think only the chest books yes
someone like the management he had
something on management
he had this putin book like this winter
is coming it was mostly about Putin's
Russia I think I don't know I mean likes
cuz I like a Sparrow's chest but some
other things were really weird but I've
just like I wasn't Cologne when he
showed his book wasn't a ship yeah and I
was a little bit impressed by I mean he
he he talked about Putin and I mean
there was some kind of question if he
wasn't afraid that something might
happen to him and so on yeah and he knew
about some dangerous things that might
be happen but he said okay I I rely a
little bit on my fame you know that I'm
everybody knows me but I had the feeling
he wasn't really comfortable you know
with the idea that I mean some something
might happen it's not a wrong assumption
I can always be I mean you sometimes
think I probably you're safe
maybe am but but he did it because he
felt it was right to do you know that
what I mean
so yeah I Rex is right Kasparov had some
pretty weird ideas about history I know
that was always very strange for me to
read yeah yeah but actually I just saw
from some professors in history that a
lot of stuff is in fact invented not not
really true you have the problem with
the time also how you say like 1400
after Christ and stuff like this and
there are so many changes in
in this in the calendar also there are
also some years missing totally because
you needed to change to change stuff and
the lot has to do with the year that
it's not exactly like 364 days whatever
and so many many years there are some
technical issues also and yeah my
nemesis fury that for example a Shalimar
colleague also never existed and this is
pretty crazy because the the evidence is
pretty overwhelming but it's not a bad
idea to think outside of the box but
once the new wallet is it's a bit
strange sometimes reminds me of those
people who think that it is actually
flat you know isn't it you know can you
prove for sure ok what I'm doing here is
to prove that this deep on is more of a
weakness than a strength that could work
maybe it doesn't I will try not that
many squares for the for the night left
huh yeah but I'm threatening maybe okay
yeah I think if I just if I just get get
get trades I should wind upon
oh I was thinking maybe I'm wrong but
usually the deep one gets weak the
moment the Queen's off and this is the
case here
Finland doesn't exist theory sounds good
I mean Finland probably does exist a
friend of mine has been has been to
Finland and he says it's damn cold so it
probably exists it's but maybe he's was
not infinite it was like Columbus he
thought he wasn't yeah you know yeah hey
maybe okay
did I make a mistake there it's possible
I am that I cannot win now because I
shouldn't have taken it immediately
hmm that's it's a bits of Shamer that's
a real real shame
no he wasn't in Sweden he told me you
must be he was in Estonia and Latvia and
then was crossing over to to Finland hmm
man that's bad I have to draw that was
stupid
I was extremely stupid I was just
talking too much I think it also good
game yeah well okay yeah but I think I
should just win the pawn you know I mean
hehe went here and I can do I can just
win this by by being systematic about it
yeah like 94 a5 and surround it and win
it ultimately
Swedish what's Finland has been Swedish
for a longer time that has been finished
okay yeah thanks for the game of the
winter so like star yeah let's go
Tom there's a read it on the Finland
conspiracy that's let's go that's the
information of the day okay so you want
to the Sicilian you collide I want that
like star wins because I like tal as
well okay maybe I can disturb you a
little bit saying ring the bell
I don't know yeah but you've been to
that the port's tournament when tower
was around yeah yeah and it was
incredible really like the atmosphere
around him I mean it was pretty small
and yeah it was some kind of magic
around I don't know it was really really
really great to see him and tell what is
what is really remarkable about him is
that there are many written accounts
there like people who met him and um and
so on and it's not a single bad word
about him not a single one absolutely
nobody ever said you know name he was
kind of whatever yeah it simply does not
exist yeah everybody loves him
absolutely and there have been accounts
which I think a great year that he was
when he was um I want some
listen to an interview really long one
with the Shamanov the multiple US
Champion who is originally from from
Riga and he learnt chess really from
tall as a kid and he said that tile was
always analyzing with the kids and in
doing doing stuff at in Riga and he was
really working with all the kids yeah
like absolutely even the ones who were
really not very talented it was just so
much enjoying showing them the game him
great yeah I think you also like we
talked about buyo before well I think he
was also student tell ya what kitchen is
lifted yes for we go yeah yeah yeah and
you hear of the story with the
hippopotamus yeah yeah funny story ever
I was thinking about or talking about
his way of calculating him okay so here
we have a somewhat weird transposition
into I don't know what it is
it looks like a g6 line sometimes it
looks a little bit yeah I mean it had a
drag we went into a dragon somehow okay
I'm not sure about this I want to
develop I want to do do you like the
structure was black
what do you often play f6e or whatever
one two two or yeah if six wasn't was a
thought I was thinking about it I don't
think hooligans was taught by different
omegas from the ICC yeah yeah I mean he
is also from that we have spiriva yeah
like start says haven't you read coach
knows no more I did of course yeah I
mean I'm not sure they're the cultural
wrote more than one book em so I've read
I think twice each one twice
I read two books I think a question I
have interesting history of course
interesting story okay he I'm
threatening to take
to window bishops Oh bloom I'll pawn up
I just read it in the tips of Magnus
Carlsen if you were a minute ahead is
roughly a yo-yo power behind your palm
I'm not sure about it I don't think that
this was a good idea
that's the f-pawn they have this as well
that could be awful
King King d3 evident now I can just do
it with simple means shouldn't remove
that probably you never know
and now we've got 120 so as I predicted
it increases over time and it's like
four five
oh it's like going for that I can't keep
the bishop this should be school to here
thanks for the follow never play of 6uu
hey you thanks for the game catch insko
never play a six young haven't been
feingold follow I guess so who else is
on we still have got six challenges come
come come come come
okay Bionic mender house yeah I think
we'll be on for like 15 minutes or so
let's do one or two more games I have to
look at the Ruka and games that I do
tonight otherwise I'm going to make a
complete fool of myself so let's play
bionic man and yeah he's really yeah so
Eric's thanks a lot for the cheer so
easily you can also split to a four
right so that I can then you have nice
per Toby you know this this makes
perfect sense yeah I mean like it's not
you can't play Bishop g4 which is
sometimes yeah if it doesn't really
doesn't really fight all that much
against our ideas yeah chess temple has
endgame training you're completely right
Lord Kinbote but my my
tonight is Luke endings with many ports
and many pawns means many mistakes so I
I should really look at them a little
bit especially the ones that a friend
sent me and he told me yeah these are
good look at those and okay
I didn't didn't yet look at the middle
but can't you take just like the two
baretsky and that's my backup him if I
failed to prepare anything I take the
endgame menu and do something random I
really like the endgame book of Karass I
think it was practical and yes because
it was just you know important end games
I like that although it's it's old I
mean a lot of stuff is what do you think
about all this she wants stuff and all
the very old books now there are too
many mistakes that you don't want to I
heard that I heard that sure one is
supposed to be very accurate actually I
heard that I've got I haven't checked
myself but somebody somebody told me you
know sharona's is fairly accurate I have
those three or four books in the shelf
and it feels very comfortable to have
them but I never touched them so it's
like collecting books and you think it's
always possible to read them yeah
Finland has one Grandmaster Diaz
positive score against Calvin did Todd's
induced against Tomy 9 it back once said
it's possible there was a game him yeah
this setup is actually quite quite nice
you're making chess look nerdy I don't
know just a spot how do you look like
you should stream yourself and see how
nerdy you look so we have what I'm doing
is I wanted to try to play with g4 but
the way he's playing it it doesn't look
like I should I'm able to do that
actually this stuff were vegan in f4
with the bishop traded three thing about
plan G for you sometimes yeah G for I
was probably because he said f4 okay
sorry yeah Allen rook g10 it was my idea
but what I wanted to say is that this is
a setup when you tried to bishop and get
to get these strong pieces this is Fanny
nice it's nice to play I had this on the
boat a couple of times as a junior
player when I sometimes played be free
to confuse people it worked pretty well
but back in the day it was even more
exotic than today yeah I had a plan in
the club he always played this and he
often played it with Bishop d3 him and
then he just tried to check make you an
HSN yeah like Nascar oh I had a classic
okay so it looks kind of nice
yeah your pieces both in the center very
very well one good thing is that time
why say it looks pretty good said to
move maybe not yeah why why did he do it
I mean you've got 97 coming because of
this okay
yeah I was thinking if he thinks with
the pawn FG 5 and if you like here so
you just claim you have a better endgame
with a knife against the bishop yes yeah
so exchange rooks
and with what something like that yeah
before I go before I haven't why don't
you play something like rook c1 or
something that just yeah yes you can
activist proxy to later on okay you want
just together yeah I'm always as
tactical thing you you're greedy yeah
yeah you want to i'm just greedy the
rook is trapped and d4 look these guys
please give me an opinion on Demetri
kymaro streaming with Fiona have you
seen that have you listened to it what
do you think I have to follow him I only
Chester so that when he actually gets on
I can I can follow that you should
really get a Twitter stream wait tactics
the chemistry was legendary
yeah rook takes d3 is the best driver
black you should try that yes I
recommend it heavily yeah watch the
Camaro stream it's really cool
that's really hard I mean you have to to
play to check it so you have to do all
everything it wants him that's
definitely true it would be better even
than taking the rook get the full rope
is better than the exchange you are
sorry yeah I'm greedy I know I'm not
bent on chess calm I'm not really all
that often on chess calm but I'm not
been there
oh it sure could okay let's go one more
game against Shukra to one of my
toughest opponents yeah look at that
he always beats me to Fred yeah I know
so she quitting give it a go if you
winded [ __ ] I said from the che cosa
from the wizard like the comedian the
German comedian who has sometimes who is
not like you can that's indeed true we
am bending me somewhere for bad behavior
whom I don't see that happen and what am
i doing yeah I'm playing the roles I
have no clue right this is the main idea
of what I'm doing
are you from Belgium why did think he
come from Belgium
that's a cool cool idea did sure that's
what I meant
yes she attended sure no no I'm not from
Belgian I played in the Belgium league
for some years and I have no clue what
I'm doing here absolutely
he should have write a reference for a
book about this then you know what
you're doing yeah that's true
now I don't speak Belgian what is but
it's Belgian he said a new language
probably yes and how do I actually not
get killed by e5 he's killing you again
yeah probably so if she Cortez is really
real emesis of me this euroleague us
only Chester he also killed he always
also wins against me on chess 24 always
wins against me it's a bet that's a bad
position again
hmm I was thinking it would take on dat
Connie Firebird
can you play 95 anyway no can't okay no
and I do a great thing I can think after
taking it I was thinking I was thinking
it just goes Queen c7 now that's a bit
of an annoyance I cannot go Quincy 5:2
to 57mm not it's not a really nice
position not nice try to fall try to not
fall behind on the clock all that much
this this could be okay at least
I'll ever know I don't know it's that a
good idea
I go king in 797 that looks a bit of
trapped isn't a for also look for him
maybe first of all I'm trapping the
friggin rook I can go to d6 I just see
it now pretty late
still late that I saw that rooks III
rook d7 King e8 rook checks b7 look C to
even afford yeah this this I would have
I have to pay the money piece
but wasn't it a product maybe if you
take and he and then at the end you have
rooks he to check and then maybe maybe
you're right maybe you're right I was
somewhat irritated maybe you're right
the moment I saw I have the better
minded piece I was thinking okay I know
you have those two points rolling
rolling rolling
and I'm better on the clock I'm a head
on the clock let's assume you had just
one of the pounds on see foyer of the
two points would you still say black ass
back up better because of the bishop or
not sorry which one bear just put one of
your two points in the center to see
four and would you say black is better
see farm that depends
in 94 I overlooked it actually it's
probably not a big deal Romford it's
just it's too good already but his first
win against him yeah I've won once on
just 24 but lost the other games it's
really a tough opponent yes thanks a lot
for the game she quit okay so um like
it's there one final game um I will do
one three zero game who is on I think
this is the oldest challenge so let's go
with the oldest challenge h3g 4 is good
against the night of iya that that's my
recommendation if somebody asks me
didn't play Fisher himself fighting
sometimes HT g4s one was one of Fisher's
favorite lines this is all this is a
very nice position for white and you
don't miss a black square bishop no no
they just took quick what you get on the
Queen sir King said it's just too quick
I could have taken the pawn maybe I
should have taken the pond but you just
it's just too too much of an attack
coming
you can probably argue about some of my
decisions here but in three minutes yes
I'd try to be practical a little bit
more why not what's going on you
I can't just take the Sun so chick it
doesn't really it doesn't really amount
to that much maybe later Ruby for years
maybe I'm a I shouldn't have taken but I
wanted to but at the pawn
what's its a thread and the famous
famous last words
yeah it's got it here he had clearly
five he had 25 yes you are Antonio is
right yeah I completely completely
screwed it up
he had 25 yes absolutely
okay
binbin
to relax down you want to do something
on that server
yeah if seven is if the idea as usual I
have that I try with the most the
simplest and less inventive idea ever
what Red Queen said also is right up my
alley if I'm something up that's Red
Queen's
kingi same shaker would be funny
- go look f7
countercheck I always like that is like
in the movies she recognized that
whenever this chick attached s in the
movies and you have like chick and the
other guy says check yeah kinda like
actually move is where you see that this
the board you see is an actual game or a
good game I hate it when you have like a
super genius player play against each
other
and then one thing wants to conquer the
world and when you see a freak position
it's foods made yeah it's completely
wrong yeah I think in the in the Harry
Potter movie this is really a very good
they didn't think they had a they had
some really good advice I am yeah I like
that those little things where you think
okay yeah okay guys thanks for watching
yeah I hope you enjoyed it little bit of
a different stream it's a bit of an
afternoon stream and thanks for me hey
Michael being around here maybe it's a
huge thank you thank you thank thanks
thanks for the audience thanks for
watching I'll be back on Monday my
regular show I'm not sure then I do
something on the weekend because I have
to have to record some some video but so
money for abattoir yeah okay thanks a
lot guys bye bye